[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMUEL LEVIN: When I was
16 I came home from school.
And I sat down at
the dinner table.
And I put my head in my hands.
And I said, you know what,
I can't take it anymore.
And the problem was
that it seemed to me
that pretty much everyone
around me was unhappy.
So I went to a public school
in Western Massachusetts.
I was in my junior year.
And it seemed to me that
pretty much all of my friends
were going through their
days disengaged, not happy,
and not learning much.
And they looked
like sort of drones.
I'd go to school,
and they looked
like they were being
passed through the day,
by bell after bell,
worksheet after worksheet,
and then going home
to do their homework.
They just seemed like lifeless.
That's not to say all the time.
They had their
moments of greatness,
and a good teacher,
or a good project.
But most of the time they
just seemed pretty miserable,
my friends.
And I myself, I
was pretty happy.
I liked school.
I was a school person.
I had a few teachers I liked.
Plenty I didn't.
But I was pretty content.
But what was driving me crazy
was that so many of my friends
just seemed miserable.
And I suppose that
would have been OK
if in spite of being miserable
they were becoming enlightened.
So maybe you just got to buckle
down and be unhappy for four
years in order to learn, right?
But the problem was
they didn't really
seem to be learning either.
They weren't coming
out the other end of it
with all sorts of knowledge,
or gaining enlightenment
in a way that would allow
them to lead better lives,
or be more thoughtful people,
or make better decisions.
And so there was that.
And even that might have
been OK if I just thought,
well, you know what,
high schoolers suck.
I mean, we high schoolers,
we like to play video games,
and spend all our time
online, and on social media.
And we can't really expect
high schoolers to learn much.
You know, they're just kind
of rebels, or whatever.
But I knew that wasn't the
case, because for three years
previously when I
was a freshman I had
started a garden at my school.
And it was a student
run garden that
grew food for the cafeterias
in our school district.
And in the garden
I saw the opposite
of what I saw in the classroom.
In the garden I saw kids showing
up at 6:00 in the morning
to harvest vegetables
for the cafeteria.
Not getting credit,
or money, or anything.
I saw them giving up
their weekends to work,
to harvest, and weed, and water.
I saw them going all
through the summer,
skipping sports, family
dinners, whatever, all of that
because they had committed to
this idea of changing the way
our school ate.
So I knew that high schoolers
had enormous potential,
that when they put
their minds to something
they couldn't be stopped.
So that's what
really began to eat
at me was the mismatch between
the lifeless people I saw
in the classroom who had to
be cajoled into just writing
their name on a piece of
paper and then the ones
I saw getting up at 6:00 in the
morning to go out in the cold
and pick raspberries.
And that really began to
just drive me up the wall.
And so that day I came home
and I said, you know mom,
it's so crazy to me.
It doesn't make any sense,
and I can't take it anymore.
And was expecting her to
be like, oh well, you know,
suck it up, or
whatever, that's life.
That's high school.
You'll get to college one
day and that'll be fun.
But she didn't.
She turned to me and said,
OK, then why don't you
start your own school.
And I began to think,
OK, maybe I will.
And so I started to spend my
junior year of high school
thinking that I
could actually start
a school within my high school
in Western Massachusetts.
And I began to
think, well, maybe we
could do it differently.
Maybe we could change
things so that we
could see what I
saw in the garden,
and on the basketball court,
and in the baseball field,
we could see that
in the classroom.
And the big idea that began to
occur to me in my junior year,
as I started to plan this
and design this new school,
was that the difference between
what I saw in the garden
and what I saw in the classroom
came down to autonomy.
Because in the garden
we were the owners.
It was our thing.
It was our garden.
We were responsible for it.
And no one was
telling us to do it.
No one was there to save us
from it when things went wrong.
It was ours.
And in the classroom
us 14 to 18 year olds,
adolescents, becoming
adults, we had no autonomy.
We were being told what
to learn, how to learn it,
then given a test to be told
whether we had learned it
or not.
So it began to occur to me that
there was no wonder that we
weren't engaged.
It was no wonder that
we weren't passionate.
we weren't finding
things we were excited about.
Because we were at
a time in our lives
when we craved more than
anything autonomy, and yet
we were being
given the opposite.
We were having our lives
completely structured
within the school day.
And so I began to think
that if I did start a school
it would be a
student run school.
Yeah.
SUSAN ENGEL: OK.
I'll tell my side of the story.
When Sam walked in that day
and sat down on the table
and put his head in
his hands, I mean
he really looked miserable.
And he looked furious.
But that wasn't the
first time I had seen
a kid frustrated at school.
First of all, Sam is the
youngest of my three sons.
And they all went to
a local public school.
And I had heard so many
stories on so many afternoons.
The good thing
and the bad thing.
The wonderful chance
to write a cool story.
The terrible time a teacher
unfairly graded a test.
The victory in a
basketball game.
And the cool mural painted
on a wall, but also
the mean teacher
who sent you out
to the whatever, the bad office.
And all along I
thought to myself, OK,
you take the bad with the good.
Overall it's a
pretty good thing.
And it's what it is.
It's what high school has to be.
On that day when he came home
so filled with frustration
and so filled with disgust
at the disparity between what
he had seen in the
garden and what
he saw going on in the
hallways in his school
I had sort of a series
of light bulb moments.
The first light bulb was that we
had been distracted as a nation
by the idea of the super
highs and the super lows.
So everybody knows about
the desperate stories
of children who are so
miserable or so marginalized
at school that they drop
out, that they give up,
that they do something terrible.
And on the other hand, the super
highs, the victorious kids who,
against all odds, succeed
or do something fantastic.
And as a country
we had forgotten
to think about the vast middle.
We had assumed that that was
OK, that as long as you got by,
as long as you got a few good
grades or one fun basketball
game, it would be OK.
And that that was a
terrible mistake, because OK
was not good enough.
The second light bulb moment
I had came from the fact
that I'm a developmental
psychologist.
So I know quite a bit about
the most contemporary research
on what adolescents are
like, what they need,
what the pitfalls are.
And I realized during
that light bulb moment
that high school is
almost perfectly designed
to be the opposite of what
high schoolers are like
and what they need.
And that, in fact,
high schools spend
most of their time, teachers,
administrators, school policy
makers, thinking
of ways to limit
what they see as the potential
disasters of adolescence.
Whatever you can do to keep
kids from running wild.
Whatever you can do to make
them sit in their seat.
Whatever you can do to keep them
from ganging up with each other
and doing bad things.
And whatever you can do to
keep them out of control.
And in spending so much energy
and time thinking about ways
to limit the negative
potential of teenagers,
they had neglected
to think about what
you could do to design an
environment that would make
the most of the
incredible potential
of the adolescent
period of life.
Because, in fact,
it is arguably one
of the two most important
developmental phases
of our whole lives.
Maybe sort of infancy
and toddlerhood
is one, where you learn to walk,
and navigate the social world,
and you begin to
understand symbols.
I mean, an enormous
amount goes on then.
And then again in adolescence
this major transformation
takes place.
And we had sort of ignored
it in our high schools.
And that led to the
third light bulb,
which is that, in fact, there
is this huge transformation that
happens during adolescence.
You start high school, you're
still pretty much a kid.
And in our culture you're
treated like a kid,
without the freedom
of responsibility,
and also the openness and
the privileges of childhood.
And yet, by the time
you leave high school
we expect you to be well
on your way to adulthood.
After all, by the time
you're 18 you can vote.
You can legally get married.
You're supposed to be somewhere
on the path to choosing
a professional life or
a professional identity.
And not to mention the fact that
we would happily send you off
to fight in a war,
and kill people and be
killed for your country.
That's at 18.
At 16 we hardly let
you do anything.
And, in fact, as Sam
said, we don't even
trust you to tell time.
We ring a bell when you
should get up out of your seat
and go to the next activity.
And suddenly it
made no sense to me
that adolescents should
be squandered in that way,
or neglected in that way.
Which is why I was so
interested to watch
him develop this school.
SAMUEL LEVIN: And in a
much less articulate way,
I began to be frustrated
by all of these things too.
And in my junior year
as I started to think,
well, we could have
a student run school,
and if we did that students
would be making choices
and so therefore engaged and
really able to learn things.
They could learn to be
responsible, and learn
to dig deeply into
things, as opposed
to just be told to flip
from subject to subject.
I began to think
all these things.
It also occurred to me
that I couldn't just
think about it, that this
actually had to happen.
I actually had to start school.
And so that's what I set about
doing in my junior year was
going to my school
and saying, listen,
I'm going to start a
student run school here.
And of course they
just said, OK, fine,
that makes sense,
and let me do it.
No.
So, of course, as a public
school it wasn't that easy.
There was a lot of
backlash, because I
said we should start
a student run school.
And they said that's
the craziest thing
we've ever heard.
But I started going
through that process,
meeting after meeting,
curriculum steering committee,
school board, parents,
teachers, everyone,
to try to say, listen, look
at how much doesn't make sense
about what we do.
Look at how much we
know about adolescence
and what we could achieve if
we made some simple changes.
But also to say, look
at what we're doing now.
Look how many kids are failing.
Look how many kids
who are "succeeding"
are getting almost nothing
out of this process.
And yet still I got backlash.
To give you a little
example, in, I don't know,
my thousandth meeting with this
curriculum steering committee I
was going on saying,
well, you know,
I had gone to them
so many times before.
And each time they'd sent me
back to the drawing board.
And I'd come back to
them saying, well,
what about this, and
what if we do this?
And one teacher was
getting so frustrated,
he was getting visibly
red in the face.
And finally, late in the
meeting he just blurted out,
you know what, it's
ridiculous to think
that high schoolers could be
trusted to learn on their own.
And I think that just paints a
picture of the kind of response
that we got.
But meeting after
meeting, day after day,
month after month, we
convinced them to do it.
And so in my senior year,
the fall of my senior year,
we got eight students from
all different backgrounds,
kids who were planning to drop
out, getting straight F's,
to straight A
students who planned
to go to the top colleges to
come together and take charge
of their high school education.
SUSAN ENGEL: So
one of the things
that fascinated me, so Sam
would come home from school
and say, you can't believe it.
They said we can't do this.
Or it won't work.
Or the teachers
won't let us do it.
And I began to
notice actually it
comes down to a very simple
idea, how afraid grownups are
of teenagers.
And I began to think about
what was driving that fear.
And I'm just going
to name a few.
One of their fears, and I've
referred to this before,
is that teenagers left to
their own devices, left
to learn on their own,
you'll have total anarchy.
That they won't
follow any rules,
that they won't have any plans,
that they won't do any work.
And, in fact, all
of the research
shows, in a famous
study where students
had little beepers that
beeped them throughout the day
to find out what they were
doing, who they were with,
what kind of project
they were doing,
or activity they
were doing, what
they were feeling and thinking.
That research shows that
actually, when teenagers
have a choice over
what they're doing,
they are their most engaged,
their most purposeful,
their most hardworking,
and their most
interested in taking
on serious challenges.
So, in fact, it's not as
if giving students a choice
makes them dive into
chaos and anarchy.
Quite the opposite.
It makes them focus.
It makes them try hard.
As a second example,
there's a terrible fear
that if teenagers
get together, they'll
just cause a lot of damage.
And as I mentioned
before, there's
a lot of effort put on keeping
kids apart from each other.
They can have five
minutes between classes
to walk down the hall,
but then they separate.
Don't sit too near one another.
You can work a little bit,
but don't work together
a little bit, but don't
work too much because you'll
borrow each other's ideas.
All of the research shows that,
I mean you must find this here,
when students can work
with someone they like,
they do better work.
When teenagers are in
the company of peers
they do take more risks,
but many of those risks
are good risks.
And in some settings
we see that as one
of the goals of education,
learning how to take a risk.
One of the other things that
scared the grownups that Sam
was talking to was the
idea that grownups would
become useless, or irrelevant.
Because if teenagers
were learning together,
what would the grownups do?
In fact, we know from research
that the most important role--
Adults are very important
during adolescent development.
We've known this
since Erik Erikson
in the beginning of
the 20th century.
Teenagers need adult role models
that are not their parents.
But actually by
changing the role, which
I think Sam is going
to tell you a little
more about, by changing
the role of adults
you free them from
being minders,
and keepers, and
disciplinarians,
and you find a way to let them
actually be mentors and develop
mutual relationships.
That's what the research shows
teenagers need, relationships
with grownups.
Not to be watched over.
Finally, one of the
fears that the grownups
had in Sam's school,
and grownups ever
since as we've talked
about this idea,
is that if you took them out of
the regular conventional school
system, they'd miss
something very important.
How would they keep up with
their English, or their math,
or whatever it is that the
conventional school was
offering them?
It might create such a
gap in their education.
And what's remarkable
about that, if you
look across the country at the
data we have about schools,
is that it turns
out they wouldn't
be missing very much at all.
The data on what kids learn
in a given semester or a year
are not very impressive.
And the less a kid likes the
school, the less impressive
their learning is.
So, in fact, it's hard
for me to understand quite
why grownups feel so much
fear at the idea of students
choosing their own education.
SAMUEL LEVIN: And I
think one thing that
happened that semester was
we showed how many of those
fears were unfounded.
So we set out in the
fall of my senior year
and ran our own school.
And the setup was simple.
We had our afternoons set aside
for an individual endeavor,
which meant that you could
do anything you wanted,
as long as it could
take the whole time.
It was meaty, and you
were excited to do it.
Build a boat.
Write a book.
Whatever.
And in the mornings
we did academics.
So we did the sciences,
where you ask questions,
and the languages, the
mathematical and English
languages where we read books,
chose books for each other,
wrote, read our reading
aloud to each other,
and explored exciting
math problems.
And to paint a little picture
of what that was like,
I'll tell you a story from the
very beginning of that school.
So we started out with doing
the sciences in the morning.
And the idea was
everyone would come up
with their own natural and
social science question
to start the week.
And then you'd spend that
week pursuing the answer,
reading books, talking to
teachers, experts, whatever.
And then on Friday you'd teach
it to the rest of the group.
And as we started out,
it was really exciting.
Everyone was coming up
with their questions.
Oh, I want to know
why crying evolved.
Or I want to know what really
initiated World War II.
That kind of stuff.
And yet there was one student
who I was worried about.
We were just getting started.
I just spent an entire
year convincing my school
and everyone that
we could do this.
But I didn't know.
I mean, it could
have been a disaster,
and it would all be on me.
So I was nervous.
And there was one
student who had
his older brother dropped out.
He was planning to drop out.
He didn't do well in classes.
He didn't get along
with his teachers.
And I was worried.
You know, in those
first weeks he
was sort of sitting
there looking kind
of grumpy and disinterested.
And I was worried, what if
he just doesn't do anything?
What if they're right?
What if when they said, oh, some
kids just don't have interests,
they were right?
And so that first day of
question asking everyone
had gone, and it got to
Rix, who was the kid.
And he just didn't say anything.
And everyone was like
Rix, what about you man?
And he was like,
don't have anything.
And, you know, Tim was
like, well, come on.
We all thought of
questions over the weekend.
You've got to have something.
And he's like nope.
And then another
student said, well,
you must be interested
in something.
What are you interested?
And he said, nope, not
interested in anything.
And I was like, oh, here we go.
Yep.
I was wrong.
And then his friend,
surprisingly,
who was someone who I
never would have guessed
would be the person to speak up,
because he was also someone who
didn't like school, he said,
well, what about that book
you were looking at earlier?
You know, that
copy of Sam's book.
You were looking at that.
So you must have been
pretty interested in that.
And I was like, what
book is he talking about?
And then I remembered,
I was reading
"A Brief History of Time."
And Rix said, well, yeah, I
mean, I guess like infinity
and space and stuff.
That's kind of interesting.
And I was hit with two
different emotions at once.
I was so excited that Rix
was interested in something.
I was like, yes, great.
And then I was like, oh
no, too bad it's something
so impossibly complex
that he could never
make any progress on it.
And for a split second I
thought about saying, well,
maybe not for this first week.
Maybe what do you think, you
should try something else?
And then I thought,
you know what,
that's not the point of this.
The point of this is for people
to pursue their interests.
I don't want to make him
decide he's not interested.
And so I didn't say anything.
And the week went along.
And everyone else, I'd
see John racing off
with a stack full of
books to the library,
or Dakota coming in with muddy
boots and a bag full of leaves
that she had collected.
And yet, day by day,
I saw Rix sitting
in the corner with the same
textbook, in the same spot,
on the same page, looking
over and over again.
And I worried.
Then one day I went
over-- Oh, so one day I
noticed that my
book was missing,
my "Brief History of Time."
And I saw Rix at lunch.
And he said, yo, I
borrowed your book.
And I was like, OK,
well, what do you think?
And he's like, I don't
know, it's confusing.
And I was like, well, do
you want to talk about it?
I mean, yeah, when I read
it, I couldn't really-- I've
had to read it two times.
You know, I find it
pretty confusing too.
I don't really get it.
And he's like no, not really.
I don't want to talk about it.
And then Friday came, and we had
our very first day of teaching.
And everyone stood up
there and taught us.
And John scribbled the
chalk boards, covered them
with notes.
And Dakota dumped
her bags of leaves
and explained the
hypothesis she had.
And I sat there just amazed.
I had never seen
kids look so excited
and engaged standing at
the front of a classroom.
But all along I sat
there thinking, well,
what's going to
happen when Rix goes?
And finally it was his turn.
And everyone turned to him.
And he had his pants
were sagging down.
And he sort of
said with a smile,
he was like, well, I guess
I'm supposed to go now, huh?
And he stood up, and he
sort of tucked his hat
low over his eyes so we
couldn't really see his face.
And he went up there and he
pulled out a rubber band.
And he said, so I'm going
to explain something
to you called a Mobius strip.
And if I was surprised
to hear the term Mobius
strip coming out of Rix's mouth,
I only had to wait and listen.
Because for the next 40
minutes he began to talk.
And he said, so you can use
this rubber band to understand,
you know, and he and
he launched into it.
And you could have
heard a pin drop.
We barely moved in
that whole time.
And he finally explained
about the big bang.
And then he tried to
explain the difference
between finite and
infinite universes.
And he said, that part's
real hard to explain.
I tried to explain to
my brother yesterday,
and he didn't really get it.
So I don't really
even get it anymore.
Or yeah, like so this
might not make any sense,
but there's this hotel, and it's
kind of like an infinite hotel.
And I don't know who started
it, but pretty soon we
were all clapping.
And, you know, Rix
was embarrassed,
but he was smiling.
SUSAN ENGEL: So when Sam
would come home from school
he'd talk about
the different kids
in the independent project,
and tell me who they were,
and what they were doing.
And when he started
talking about Rix,
you know, the scraggly guy
who's not doing well in school,
I love boys.
I've got three boys.
So I thought, oh my god,
he's probably this great kid.
And no one understands him.
And once again, teachers aren't
giving some boy a fair shake.
And then one day I
was in school to watch
a basketball game or something,
and this really grungy
looking boy, with lank
hair, and low pants,
and sort of slumped over,
and not nice looking at all,
and Sam called me over and
said, mom, this is Rix.
Rix, this is my mom.
And I couldn't believe it,
because I thought, this is Rix?
This isn't the kid I
thought I would love,
and that I thought all
the teachers would love.
In fact, I don't think I would
love him if I were his teacher.
And he reminded me,
this story reminds me
of the same old story I've
heard again and again,
of a kid who didn't seem
like academic material.
He wasn't appealing to grownups.
I knew, as I found out
later, he was from a family
where there were no
readers or no talkers.
He probably had parents who
hated school, or even dropped
out of school.
So he never expected
to like school.
And he made teachers expect
that they wouldn't like him.
He's the kind of kid that
teachers look at and think,
this kid is not
academic material.
And the next thought they have
is the big mistake in teaching,
which is they think
this kid is not
going to do well academically,
so this kid must not
be a thinker.
And that's one of the great
flaws, great mistakes we make,
which is to assume that just
because a kid doesn't look
like he's going to
do well in school,
he must not be a thinker.
The fact is, we know from
a great deal of research,
that every single child
is born a thinker.
Everybody loves to think
about the world around them.
I just heard today
a conversation
about two little five year
olds having a heated argument
in the back of their car about
the space-time continuum.
That's not unusual.
And in the first years of
life every kid is a learner.
As I've said, they
learn to talk.
They learn to navigate
the social world.
They learn all kinds of
rules and complex topics.
As they go on in school, for
many children, a kid like Rix,
that begins to be worn
away, because they're
taught that if they're
not doing well,
they can't think
about good big topics.
And Sam, in the moment that
he struggled with Rix's topic,
suffered from the
same kind of doubt
that teachers often suffer from.
Which is when he
thought to himself,
this might be too
complicated for Rix,
it's because he had the
impulse that if you struggle
academically we should give you
something easier to work on.
Because better to be successful
at something easy than struggle
with something hard.
The mistake there is
to equate easy and hard
with boring and interesting.
Because often the easy tasks we
give kids who struggle are also
boring tasks.
No one likes to work at
something that's boring.
And we turn knowledge
into a ladder, where
all the boring stuff
is at the bottom,
but you've got to do it to get
to the good stuff at the top.
But if you're a kid in school,
whether you're 8 or 14,
why are you going to want
to get past that bottom rung
of the ladder?
Who is going to want
to get to infinity
if they have to learn
the number line first,
and the number
line is difficult?
Much better to get
interested in infinity,
and then decide that you'll
never understand it completely
if you don't find out more
about the number line.
What Sam and Rix
discovered together
in the time they
sat together had
to do with realizing
that everybody
is wading into the unknown
when they delve into new ideas,
that everybody wants to
think about big ideas.
We know this, by the
way, from listening
to what teenagers talk about
when they're not in school,
or write songs about, or
like to go to movies about.
They like to think about love,
and justice, and conflict.
They're interested
in the big ideas.
And you don't need to
know a lot about something
to begin to think about it.
When Sam said to Rix, I
don't really get it either,
he was making them
an intellectual team,
and he was inviting Rix into
the pleasures of the unknown.
So for Rix, that
period of time when
he struggled to
grasp infinity was
his first, most
authentic experience
of being a true intellectual.
And that's what school should
provide every teenager.
SAMUEL LEVIN: And yeah, so
we carried on that year.
In our afternoons
we learned what
it was like to really
master something.
In the mornings
we discovered what
it was like to all be
intellectuals together.
And at the end of
it we did something
called the collective
endeavor, which
was planned in for
the last three or four
weeks of the program.
The idea being that in
school we get almost no time
to truly collaborate.
We get to do like a
project here or there,
where two people team up to
make a poster or something.
But we don't get to
make something together,
to build something as a team.
And the other element of
the collective endeavor
is that it had to have an
impact on our community.
Because somehow we were supposed
to emerge from school being
better citizens, and
yet we almost never
engage with the outside world.
And so in the end we
had to choose something
to do together as a team that
would have a positive impact
on our community.
And maybe unsurprisingly,
when I turned to everyone,
or we all turned to
each other and decided
what are we going to talk
about, everyone immediately
said we've got to do
something about education.
Because what they
had discovered they
wanted to share with every other
high schooler in the world.
And so we made a film
about what we had done
and our year in education.
And we posted it online.
And we expected maybe
one of our parents
would watch it, or a
friend or something.
SUSAN ENGEL: I would watch it.
[LAUGHING]
SAMUEL LEVIN: But people
started to watch it.
And people started to
write to us and say,
hey, I want to do this
too, teachers, parents,
and most excitingly,
other students.
Saying school's
miserable for me too.
I want to get excited.
You know, I want
to discover what
it's like to love learning.
And then that year ended.
I went off to college.
I moved to England.
The independent project, which
was the name of the school
carried on.
It's now in its seventh year.
Rix graduated.
He didn't drop out.
And his individual endeavor
was learning how to cook.
He's now a chef at
a top restaurant.
And others went on to
college and to pursue careers
in the things that
they had discovered.
And my mom and I
carried on talking.
And we carried on
the conversations
that started that first
time at the dinner table
when I sat down and said
I can't take this anymore.
And eventually
those conversations
turned into this book.
Yeah.
I don't if you want to say
anything about the book.
SUSAN ENGEL: I want
you to read it.
SAMUEL LEVIN: So
those conversations
turned into that book.
And the book was a few things.
It was, like I said, the
ideas had began to form,
because we realized this
wasn't just one instance at one
school, but this was a new
way of thinking about how we
could educate our young people.
The book's also the
story, the nitty gritty
of what that was like, the
ups and downs, the failures,
the great moments,
the bad moments,
the things we did right,
and the things we did wrong.
But maybe most importantly,
or most excitingly,
the book's also a how to.
Because all those people wrote
to us, from New York City,
to Boise, Idaho, to
Australia, to Spain, saying
we want to do this.
So it's a how to for how you
can change your own school.
And maybe, for me, I
don't know, most of all,
this may not be the
case for my mom,
but it's about what that
teacher said that day when
we were first starting out.
When that teacher said
it's ridiculous to think
that high schoolers could be
trusted to learn on their own.
And that year in education, and
everything that happened after,
really is about the fact that
it's ridiculous to think that
they can't.
SUSAN ENGEL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So how would you talk
about the conventional system,
like colleges accepting this
kind of education system.
And how do you relate to
admissions of colleges?
What's the path if
somebody pursues it?
SAMUEL LEVIN: So I'll
answer from the perspective
of what we did.
And I don't know if I need
to repeat the question
or if it's recorded?
OK.
So I'll answer from
the perspective of what
we did in the
independent project,
and then as a college
professor, my mom can answer.
We conveyed it as is
often done with sort
of things that are done sort of
outside the traditional path.
So everyone who did it gets
credits equivalent to the time
that they-- for a
semester's worth of credits,
or whatever it is.
And then actually at our
school we also now send out
a letter at the front of their
sort of admissions package
saying this different
thing is here.
We have a student run
school at our school now.
And giving a sense that these
kids did something different.
And interestingly
enough, maybe this
wasn't something we
expected, but it turns out
that almost every
kid who's done it
writes about their individual
endeavor, or at least
their program in
their college essay,
because for most of
the people who did it,
it becomes the thing that
they're passionate about.
And so that's an
interesting piece.
SUSAN ENGEL: So I'll give
you two parts to the answer.
I teach at Williams
College, which
is a very selective college.
And my experience is that
when good students do
really interesting
things in high school,
it only helps their college
application process.
That said, I
honestly don't think
that's the reason to encourage
your kid to do this if you're
a grownup asking the question.
Because the whole point of
this was that what a terrible
travesty to squander a
kid's-- for those precious,
incredibly transformative,
powerful years,
thinking about what comes next.
Alfie Kohn, the
educator, has this line.
I know he's been out here
in the Palo Alto area
to talk about this where he
says, how much damage are you
willing to do to
your child to ensure
that they get into a
marginally better college?
And I think that's a
point well said, taken.
But I would also
say more broadly
that one of the
things that is most
exciting about the
independent project
is its firm
commitment to the idea
that kids of all
backgrounds and abilities
can learn together, that they
can be intellectuals together,
that that's for everybody.
And one reason I
bring that up is
many of the kids who thrive
in this kind of environment,
some are the kids who are
going to go to a great college
anyway.
And many of them from the
independent project have.
They would either way.
Many of them might
not go to college
at all if they weren't in
the independent project.
And then the
question isn't which
is the best college
they're going to get into,
but can you get them to
want to go to college?
Can you get them to
see that learning is
something they want to pursue?
And I would end by
saying, again as a teacher
at an elite
institution, that it's
my dream come true to get
students who get there not only
because they have tall
aspirations in terms
of external success or money,
but who actually come there
with a hunger to learn.
So I don't see it as having
really any downside in terms
of the path to college.
AUDIENCE: So is there
a grading scale?
Do you take tests?
When you apply to colleges, when
they're asking for transcripts,
how do you measure that someone
actually learned something
through the independent project?
SAMUEL LEVIN: Again,
I'll take a stab at it
and then see what she says.
But she'll say the
more interesting thing.
But yeah, I think in
general our approach
is that the design of the system
brings the best out of kids.
And that the experience--
I mean, one of the
things that's so amazing
is that we did awesome things.
We read more books than we had
ever read in our entire life.
People realized
they loved science.
All these incredible things.
But even if that
hadn't happened,
even if things had gone
wrong, the experience
of being responsible for our
own and each other's education,
was totally transformative,
and something
we never would have gotten.
So there are certain elements
of it that can't go wrong.
I mean, they're
responsible for that.
So that said, it was pass/fail.
They either got the
credits or they didn't.
And yeah, there are
other questions.
So certainly there
were no grades.
There were not tests.
That was not the point.
And we had constant sort of
measurement and feedback.
So we criticized each
other's on Friday.
And we had to present
our individual endeavors.
But nothing like a
sort of point grade.
SUSAN ENGEL: Yeah.
I'll say something
about measurement,
because something I'm
very interested in through
the whole K-12 spectrum.
We all suffer from this delusion
that the numbers that we're
used to seeing as measures
of the educational process
mean something.
Very few of them mean
anything, except that if you
get a high score
when you're little,
you're likely to get a high
score when you're older.
It means itself.
And so the problem with that
is once you buy into that,
the rest of it seems so fuzzy.
And I will say that I
think a second mistake is
to think that if you
reject bad measures,
it means you reject
all measures.
I think we need good
measures of the kinds
of educational outcomes
that Sam found his way to
in this school.
And there is every reason
to believe we could come up
with those measures.
I always say, you know,
I'm a psychologist.
So we measure all
kinds of things.
We measure unconscious
stereotype, the impulse
to gamble, love.
So the idea that
we couldn't measure
things like your
knowledge of books,
your real knowledge of books, or
your ability to teach yourself
something new, or
your ability to ask
a good question, which they
spent a lot of time doing,
is silly.
We could measure those things.
And then maybe we'd offer that
as a different measurement
of what we're doing.
So I think that
remains to be done,
and is begging to be done.
AUDIENCE: My name's George.
I used to be a teacher.
SUSAN ENGEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I spent two years
in the city of Chicago.
A few thoughts, and
then a question.
One is when I was
teaching in Chicago
it was an all boys
charter school.
And we were obviously very
obsessed with measurement,
like all schools,
because that ties
to how much funding we
get, is the principal going
to keep his or her job.
And in a lot of schools they
have a zero tolerance policy
on discipline.
So it's very strict,
like what you can do,
what you cannot do in
terms of behavioral,
which is very different
from what you described.
The second thing is
what I have seen--
I moved here from Chicago.
And what I have seen
here in the Bay Area,
it's very striking, because
I don't know if I want to.
I'm single.
I don't have kids.
But I'm not sure
if I do have kids
I want to raise my
kids here, because kids
from a very early age they are
already preparing for Stanford
and Berkeley.
And they need to get the scores.
They are in all these classes,
extracurricular activities,
trying to have a chance.
And it's very competitive
here to get into a good school
in the Bay Area.
Which is also very different
from what you described.
So I'm just wondering, obviously
right now, where we are,
we can't use your
system right away.
But what are some of the
tangible different changes
that we can do right now?
Maybe have some kind
of hybrid system,
or any changes we can make
right now to our system?
And one thing I
also want to add is
I went to the
University of Michigan.
And one of the best
programs I attended,
the best educational experience,
was called New England
Literature Program.
We went into the woods for six
weeks, no electronic device.
We had to turn in our
cellphone, laptop.
No heat.
No internet.
Lived there, read books, poetry,
hiking, go to national parks.
No shower.
Jump in to the lake.
Best educational
experience ever.
But I know that's also
not realistic for everyone
to do that right away.
SUSAN ENGEL: And why not?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Because
Google is probably not
going to hire people
who jump into the lake.
They want to see your resume.
So love to get your thoughts
on what we can do right now.
Thank you.
SAMUEL LEVIN: I don't know if
we're on the same page on this.
So I'll answer.
And it's a pretty simple answer.
Which is that you said that
you can't, but you should.
I mean, not you.
The school's here should.
Because the point of this was
that I think what we're doing
is wrong.
I think that most of
conventional school
is making a lot of mistakes.
And it's not educating
our young well.
And it's wasting their time.
I think that there's
a real danger.
A lot of times, when we
were first pitching this,
and since, when we
first pitching it
people said, well,
that's a great idea.
But let's just do it for a
period, because they've still
got to go to their AP class.
Or let's just do
it after school.
And this is not about tinkering.
It's about rebuilding.
And I think we have
to, whatever it takes.
It certainly won't be easy.
But we have to begin being
ready to make big changes.
SUSAN ENGEL: So I'm
going to disappoint you.
We are on the same page.
I'm going to add one
concrete piece of advice.
Because as I was
listening to you
talk about these kids who were
doing all these after school
things and trying so hard, I was
imagining the kind of question
that Sam asked the kids around
him when he was designing
the independent project.
Which is if you brought a
group of those kids together
and said, if you could spend
the next period of time learning
in whatever way you wanted,
or if you could learn whatever
you wanted, what would it
be, you might be surprised.
They might choose
to study or embark
on some pretty
impressive ventures.
Teenagers are not
without ambition.
It just may be a
different kind of ambition
than what the adults
right around them
expect them to have.
But they have aspirations.
They have desire.
They have great interest.
And so if I were a teacher in
this community, or a parent,
or had any access to kids,
I'd start very simply.
I'd get a group of
kids together and say,
what is it you really want to do
during this period of time that
will take you forward, that
will be meaningful to you?
It turns out its' a scarier
question than I ever thought.
I didn't think it was a big deal
when I said so start your own.
But I agree with Sam.
I can't imagine what would stop
people from at least asking
that question.
These are supposed to
be student led schools.
So even if a student doesn't
come up with the idea,
the role a grownup can play
is to invite the student
to think in that way.
And that's just a question.
AUDIENCE: You alluded to a
little earlier about the role
that grownups can play,
and how they become
better mentors, et cetera.
I was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit.
SUSAN ENGEL: Yes.
SAMUEL LEVIN: Yeah.
Definitely.
So the idea, the role
I envisioned for adults
was not being sort
of the lecturer
at the front of the
room, but actually sort
of being embedded
within the students.
Because certainly
we need teachers
as sources of expertise,
sources of support,
developing relationships with
adults so that they can model
to us what it's like to
both be good intellectually,
but also as a person,
and as a citizen.
And that everyone will
benefit from that process
if they're not sort
of the taskmaster.
You know, my
girlfriend's a teacher.
My cousin's a teacher.
And they spend so much of
their time having to babysit,
to be taskmasters.
And it's a waste of their time.
And it's a waste for the kids.
And so the idea is that they
would be doing the work,
you know, model what it's
like to ask a good question,
and pursue the answer, and
teach, to give criticism
alongside with the students.
All of that.
As a coach more than a lecturer
or a sage on the stage.
In that first year of
the independent project,
we pitched this idea, and
the school finally said
OK, but no teacher time.
And so we didn't get that.
We had to get a few
teachers to volunteer,
sort of sneak their time
in to spend time with us
when they could.
Likewise the school
said, OK, fine,
but you don't get a space.
So that first year we
were in the coach's office
of the girls locker room.
But anyway, that's what we got.
But what I envisioned
was this new role
for teachers, which is harder.
It's harder.
It's easier to give a
lecture than to learn
how to lead sort of as the--
To lead from behind basically.
SUSAN ENGEL: Yeah.
I mean, I'll just
echo what Sam said,
that I think that to work
with students in that way
is fascinating, and it's
very difficult to do.
I am intrigued by the idea.
So he had this incredible
advisor that year
who when he came to him with the
idea said something like, OK,
what can I do to help?
Taking that seriously
as the beginning
of your role as a teacher
is a fascinating one.
What it would take,
I mean, I'm intrigued
by the question of
what it would take
to train a group of teachers
to be good at that role.
And check back with
me in a year or two.
I'm just thinking
about what would
that guy say about how he
did it, if he was teaching
other people to do that.
So I do think it's hard.
And I can tell you
as a college teacher,
I know the difference
between the two.
Sometimes I do one and
sometimes I do the other.
But I can tell you which
one I love a lot more,
and which one leads to
a lot better learning
when I'm leading from behind.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
from the Dory, which
you guys kind of
briefly touched upon,
but I think Emerson wants
a little bit more clarity.
And it's around students
transitioning into college.
So I'm assuming even
after maybe admissions,
and transitioning into college,
where maybe it is still
a little bit more structured.
So from your guys'
perspective, how
do you see your school
in helping a student
transition into college
and be successful there?
SAMUEL LEVIN: Good question.
I've got two parts
to the answer.
One is that, funnily
enough, that turned out
in the end-- In the beginning
the big concern when
I was pitching this idea was
like, whoa, that's crazy.
Kids will burn the
building down or something.
But after they
started saying yes,
and it was like hashing
out the details,
the biggest concern
became-- Because it was only
for that fall semester.
So spring semester they had to
go back into regular classes.
And everyone became totally
terrified about the transition.
And they would talk
about it like, you know,
what about the
transition back into--
And there are various things
that are funny about that.
One is, what are
you doing in school
so that if everyone leaves for
a semester, when they come back
you think it will be a disaster.
You know, something's
wrong with a system
where you can't step away
and come back into it.
And then also
amazingly, surprisingly,
when they did have to
transition back in,
it went really smoothly.
In fact, everyone
got better grades
than they had done in
the rest of high school.
And that wasn't the
point of the program
was to get them to
get better grades.
We didn't care.
None of us cared.
And despite the fact that
everyone dreaded going back,
because they dreaded being in
a situation where they weren't
excited and they weren't
really learning much,
what they said at least was that
the reason they were getting
better grades was
because they had learned
these tools in the
independent project
to find the bit of the class
that they could pursue and make
more interesting for
themselves, or to thrive off
of the more able
kid in the class.
Things like that.
Or to teach each other.
The skills they learned
had made them better.
And the same is
true for college.
You know, you're not
going to fall apart
by having been independent,
or work with other students.
You're not going to get to
college and then be like,
I don't know how
to learn anymore.
In fact, it's the opposite.
You will learn
skills so that when
you're a bit more
independent in college
than you are in
high school, you're
going to be even better off.
And then finally, I can
speak from experience.
I went off to college.
And I couldn't believe how
often I found myself thinking,
you know, thank
god I had that time
in the independent project.
So yeah.
That's it.
SUSAN ENGEL: So I'll
just add to that
that, again, as a college
professor, the bane
of our existence, and I speak
here for many of my colleagues,
is the question, what were
you looking for in this paper?
Or what did you want?
What kind of answer did you want
when you asked this question?
By the time students
get to college
what we professors
want them to say
is this is what I
want to write about.
This is what I want
to learn about.
And we wish that they were a
little less focused on figuring
out what the test maker
wanted in the test,
and a little more
on what do I want
to get from that book, or that
lecture, or that experience.
So the more that
students can learn
to be self-directed learners
before they get to us,
the more fully they can
make use of college.
AUDIENCE: I have a couple
just like logistical questions
about where the
project independent is
today in terms of how many
people are participating.
Is it still just a fall quarter
during their senior year?
Or is it a longer program?
And then also, how
do people-- Do they
choose to get into the program?
Do they have to apply?
If it reaches a certain number,
do you have different cohorts?
Just kind of how
does it look today?
SAMUEL LEVIN: The size has
varied from around 8 to 12.
The element of
being a team, being
an intellectual
community, is essential.
And so it needs to be groups.
It can't be 300 students
mashed together,
because you get so
much out of having
a mixed ability, the whole
range of ability students,
being responsible for
each other's education.
What I would like is for there
to be 10 of those groups,
or 50, you know, not one.
And I'll come back
to that in a second.
It still only runs
for one semester.
And, again, I think that
it would benefit so much
from being a year.
I mean, one of the things
we had to deal with
was a sort of
de-orientation period.
I mean, we got there, and that
first day the bells went off,
and everyone stood up to
start shuffling their papers.
And then we were like, wait,
we've got nowhere to go.
And that just captures so much.
We had been taught
to be completely
dependent on teachers.
And we had to learn how to
be dependent on ourselves
and each other.
We had been taught that we
didn't have any interests.
And so people like
Rix had to discover
that they could have interests.
So there was this
long period of--
and I remember
feeling so frustrated,
because by the end of
it when people just
couldn't be stopped.
They were flying
off of the library,
and going off to their
individual endeavors.
I thought, man, imagine
if we had had more time,
think of what it would be
like at the end of the year.
Anyway, so I think
it should be a year.
And I may have
missed a piece of it,
so let me know if I haven't.
But I think the
point is there are
ways in which it should grow.
And if other people
try it, do it that way.
Do it for a year.
Or try it different ways.
But there is still an
incredible amount of resistance.
Every summer when I go back
home and visit my family
I wonder if finally
the ridiculous to think
people will have sort
of put a stomp on it.
And there are still parents
whose kids want to do it,
but are too worried about
them getting into college,
despite the fact that kids
have gone on to Harvard
and wherever.
And anyway, so that's it.
Yeah.
Did I miss a--
AUDIENCE: There is an
application process.
SAMUEL LEVIN: Oh yeah.
And finally that.
Yeah.
The application process.
So the idea is it
works for everyone.
So anyone who wants
to do it can do it.
The process that we did,
that I came up with,
but it could be sort of
anything, was three questions.
If you could spend six months
doing anything you wanted,
or work on anything you
wanted, what would you do?
List all of the
uses for a stick.
And what's a time when you've
worked with other people
and it hasn't gone well?
But the point of that was to
let them know the kind of thing
they were getting into.
This is going to be different.
And it's going to be your time.
Because it's important
that this is for everyone.
But you got to want to do it.
If you don't want to do it,
no one's going to force you.
That would be silly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
SUSAN ENGEL: Thank you so much.
SAMUEL LEVIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]